all right hi everybody thank you for
coming I'm Steve pity I'm the director
of the ritm center and faculty and
history American studies in ER M
um we're really excited today to host
this Showcase of student research from
the summer of 2022 as everybody here
knows these projects are some of the
many projects that Riddim had the chance
to support this past year we sponsored
37 student research projects in the
summer of 2022. those who've received
funding including people in this room
traveled far and wide deepened their
work on undergraduate and graduate
projects prepared for senior Theses and
M.A Theses and worked on chapters of
their doctoral dissertations we were
delighted this year to support students
working toward their degrees in The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences and
Yale College and also in many of Yale's
professional schools we've had the
opportunity over the last six years to
support the completion
of many student projects by helping
awardees to get to archives and research
sites where they needed to be to advance
their scholarship past recipients of
these research Awards have written
prize-winning dissertations and articles
and completed their degrees which is
just as important I'll mention too to
all of you that we're currently
accepting research and confidence travel
applications in Rhythm for the fall with
an early October deadline so check out
our Weekly Newsletter for more
information about that if you haven't
seen it you can sign up for the
newsletter if you're not already signed
up at
ritm.yale.edu by clicking on the link on
the webpage that says stay connected so
today
um we'll be hearing about summer
research projects as you know each of
our pres presenters has just three
minutes to describe their summer
research and then we'll we'll then ask
members of the audience if any one
person has a brief question to ask and
we'll give that presenter a brief moment
to respond to that question this is the
interest of keeping things moving and we
will be moving fast and demanding
concision and uh Clarity from both
presenters and audience members but I
really do hope that everyone here enjoys
themselves and that you'll join us after
the program right out here in the lounge
area for some relaxing food and drink
where we will not rush you and hold you
to three minutes to finish your Empanada
or whatever and that you'll continue the
conversation there and ask more
questions of one another so I think this
should be a lot of fun and with that I
want to turn this over to Amanda
right
okay can I start okay
um embarking on my summer internship in
Puerto Rico uh General I wanted to find
connections between the island and my
specific region of Interest Connecticut
as it pertains to Puerto Rican diaspora
my reasons for going were also a little
selfish being a Puerto Rican raised on
the mainland I've always wondered
whether I could claim Puerto Rico as a
site of belonging participating in this
internship then fulfilled both a
personal dream of spending an extended
time on the island and a professional
dream of conducting research in Puerto
Rico
the internship with archivo General in
San Juan a collaboration between Yale my
alma mater Rutgers University and the
University of Puerto Rico included five
other student interns
led by director ilda Ayala and archives
we sorted through documents from the
Puerto Rico Industrial Development
Corporation or Perico which under
operation bootstrap provided tax
exemptions to Mainline businesses in the
1940s through the 1990s
that opened factories in Puerto Rico to
rapidly industrialize the island and
stimulate its economy multiple companies
took advantage of this colonial
capitalist project including quite a few
from Connecticut I found correspondence
with the Hamilton Manufacturing Company
likely a recording equipment
manufacturer here in New Haven the mhart
corporation in Hartford Union Carbide
which is a Chemical Corporation in
Danbury the U.S Time Corporation or
watchmakers in Waterbury and the orange
pulp company Valve Corporation of
America and warnaco Inc all in
Bridgeport
in addition to making these Connecticut
Puerto Rico connections I also got to
visit the collection Puerto ricania at
UPR Studio Piedras campus in my off time
to explore one of my other research
interests Puerto Rican student activism
and education reform I collected data of
a student-led strike in 1981 over
tuition hikes at UPR data which I
anticipate using in a future Journal
article or dissertation chapter
are in all this internship was crucial
to my research interest in diasporic
studies in that I had the opportunity to
challenge The Narrative of Connecticut
as merely the passive receiver of Puerto
Rican migrants rather a Connecticut
actively shaped the very socioeconomic
conditions in Puerto Rico which prompted
migration to the mainland likewise
Gathering data about the UPR strike in
1981 enabled me to see the dynamism of
Puerto Rican student activism in the
late 20th century and even though
Mainland and Island student activists
were fighting for change in Ocean apart
a really see a part from one another
overlaps in their respective advocacy
demonstrate potential for intra-communal
influence however indirect thank you
very much for your time
[Applause]
Amanda want to talk a little bit about
one of the most challenging features of
it one of the most challenging features
um so I think for me Spanish is my
second language and
while I knew go in there that I would
need to brush up on it I think for sure
it was a challenge you know both really
trying to get a grasp with the documents
I was looking at and then also being
able to communicate confidently with the
fellow archivists I think of the first
couple weeks were just kind of trying to
psychologically wrap my head around okay
it's going to take time for the Spanish
to kind of pick up it's going to take
time for me to really feel comfortable
with these archives and that is part of
this process and it's an uncomfortable
process but I need to be okay with that
process so
yeah thank you
[Applause]
hey everyone so my tentative project is
called corrugated surrogacies cardboard
kinships in the war in Vietnam and it
looks at the history of transnational
migration and adoption through the
everyday object of the cardboard box
projected here is a series of images
that sequence the packaging and
transporting of Vietnamese orphans into
makeshift cardboard cribs during
operation baby lift at the end of the
war in Vietnam in 1975.
so operation baby lift is often narrated
in paternalistic and legalized
discourses of familial rescue and
sacrifice oftentimes these narratives
take place as interviews with or as oral
histories from adoptee survivors of
operation baby lift who have been able
to reunite with their families and or
reflect upon their experiences
assimilating to America these stories
bookend operation baby lift starting
with 1975 and following now into the
present
however as much as these interviews and
oral history's index and humanize
Refugee experiences of memory trauma and
Amnesia such genres of Storytelling are
simultaneously delimiting when
considering the fact that dozens of
Orphans either died in transit or that
thousands of other personal stories are
lost from the record as well
so thus I took this summer to turn to
the cardboard box as my primary archival
object of choice as a material that
continues to linger and litter in the
landfills and military bases across the
trans-pacific in order to re-narrate the
history of operation babylift
by shifting our attention away from the
more obvious contents of the cardboard
box to instead the form of the crib
itself I'm more interested in extending
this history of operation baby lift
Beyond 1975 as a means to trace a
broader genealogy of U.S militarism and
its mechanisms
by shifting our Focus From the babies to
the boxes themselves we are able to spot
a modern but telling detail
Miner but telling detail that of the v3c
marker which is highlighted in the red
circles this v3c label indexes a
military-grade cardboard box
specifically commissioned by and
designed for the US government in the
efficient transportation of wartime
Goods meaning that the cribs that you
see here that were used to house the
orphans war and still are the same cases
that are used to haul wartime supplies
such as ammunition and lunchbox rations
since World War II
the subtle detail led me to a series of
University archives from Cambridge to
New York with the support of ritm and
the WSS program through which I learned
that throughout the 20th century the
United States commissioned a series of
Material Science engineers and business
academics and nutritionists to
constantly optimize the production of
cardboard starting with the individual
meal kits the government constructed to
feed its soldiers since World War II to
the cardboard Crips used to house its
racialized victims during the war in
Vietnam the state sanctioned care was
not simply a matter of ethics and
emergencies instead it also involved a
careful calculation of finances as
markets and militarisms intertwine in
the management of Imperial intimacies
as I continue to examine how cardboard
folds across the history of Empire I'm
excited to continue this work at the
interdisciplinary intersections between
critical Refugee studies supply chain
studies and discard studies as a means
to understand the ongoing effect of
cardboard as an ecological as well as an
epistemological structure thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it was really
um
serendipitous it was a class that I took
with Jess actually he's right next to
you I studied the Vietnam War normally
through contemporary literature but it
was just like looking at this we had an
archival project that we had to do like
a quick like one-page story that we
wrote and I just picked this image
because it was like the first thing I
could find in my Google Drive but then
upon re-looking at it like I noticed
that these boxes were all the same shape
and I wanted to move away from more
standard oral history methods and
speculative methods so yeah thanks so
much
[Applause]
hi uh my name is Ming I'm a graduate
student in the department of psychology
and with support from the ritm I ran a
study looking at whether learning new
diagnostic information about a person
can change people's initial face-based
implicit impressions of competence for
that person and for people who share
similar facial features and whether
people do this differently for targets
from different racial backgrounds and by
implicit Impressions we're referring to
Impressions that are measured indirectly
and are less intentional than explicit
Impressions which are measured directly
by asking people about their opinions so
in our study first participants were
introduced to a competent looking Target
and depending on the condition the
target was from one of four different
racial groups they then learned either
low competence behavioral information or
neutral information about the Target and
completed a modified version of the
affect misattribution procedure which
was used to measure implicit impressions
of competence because of time
constraints I'll only present what we
found for black targets and for white
targets here so looking at the graphs
the y-axis is the proportion of more
competent trials in the affect
misattribution procedure which you can
just interpret as people's implicit
impressions of competence so higher
values indicate that the person that
people found the person to be high on
competence
um and the x-axis is the prime type and
the affect misattribution procedure the
target is denoted in green other
competent looking faces are in red and
control faces are in blue so the left
half of both graphs is when people
learned low competence behavioral
information about the Target and the
right half is when people learned
neutral information so if we first look
at the right half of both graphs we see
that the pattern is very similar for
both black targets and for white targets
so when people learned neutral
information about the target they formed
implicit impressions of competence based
on the face so both the Target and other
competent looking faces were seen as
implicitly more competent than control
phases but when people learned low
competence information about the target
so now looking at the left half of both
graphs one that Target was black people
did not change their Impressions they
still have had a high implicit
competence impressions of the Target and
of other competent looking faces however
when the target was white people did
update their implicit impressions of
their Target in line with the new
behavioral information but learning low
competence behavioral information about
one competent looking person did not
influence their impressions of other
competent looking faces so we're
planning to run another version of the
study with a larger sample to see if the
results would replicate and to explore
the possible mechanisms behind this
difference thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for this talk um how are you
measuring and standardizing the
information that you were presenting how
are you determining what was the
confidence versus
so we did a number of pre-tests before
running the main study so we came up
with four different vignettes denoting
low competence and we had independent
Raiders on prolific which is an online
participant recruitment platform where
we run our study to rate the vignettes
on competence and then also a couple of
other traits which we controlled for
foreign
so in 1965 Al Ravi a local civil rights
leader in Chicago reflected on the last
five years of protest in a speech he
said 80 days and 72 marches ago the
Chicago Freedom Movement strode into
high gear when nearly 400 of us occupied
Chicago Streets in thoroughfare on our
way to tell mayor daily to let
superintendent Ben Willis go he
continued I'm sure that most of you
realize how important it is to overcome
here in Chicago if we win here it clears
the way for liberation of every Northern
ghetto Raby pictured here had spent the
last five years as convener of the
coordinating coordinating Council of
community organizations say that five
times fast an umbrella group in Chicago
that coordinated across the many civil
rights organizations in the city a
former teacher in Chicago Public Schools
Raby was deeply devoted to the power of
Education as a liberatory mechanism he
and others believe that breaking into
and improving improving Chicago's Public
Schools would lead to an opening of the
city more broadly but despite for more
equal education didn't just start in
1960. in the Depression era so the 1930s
Chicago schools took major funding cuts
across the board schools in Chicago's
black neighborhoods mainly on the south
side of the city took the biggest hit
this led to groups like the NAACP and
the Urban League to really start
rallying around the issue of schools so
three major factors were involved in
sort of their fight again or fight for
better schools I guess the first is that
most of these schools were districted in
a way that they were segregated so given
the segregation of neighborhoods at the
time as well it was sort of linked into
that so they wanted to redistrict the
schools across the city the second issue
was curriculum so same fight we're
fighting now for more true honest
histories and classrooms things like
that and then finally the schools were
incredibly overcrowded so this is in
part due to the influx during the Great
Migration of black folks in part due to
just the lack of building especially
sort of in that Depression era when
there just wasn't the funding to do that
building and so as a result of that
overcrowding you saw a lot of schools on
double shifts so that meant that half of
the students were going to school in the
morning half we're going in the
afternoon and as you can imagine that
left a lot of students unsupervised
throughout the day and also missing you
know half of a day's education across
the board so that was really one of the
biggest issues and the issue that would
hold through through the rest of this
movement throughout the 1950s you see
tensions continuing to grow certainly
with brown V board in 1954 you see not
only in Chicago but nationally this sort
of school segregation issue becoming
more and more of a big deal and Chicago
school superintendent was Ben Willis at
the time was sort of considered the main
target of the civil rights movement
during this period again in Chicago in
particular so he came into the city in
1953 he built over a hundred schools so
on the one hand he was touted as this
great Builder and being called as Big
Ben the Builder by some but on the other
hand his policies continued to implement
segregation in schools so he instead of
building a new school in a black
neighborhood would put trailer
classrooms in the parking lot or in the
playground of that school instead of
building the new school so he certainly
was like can continuing segregation
this all led to protest of Ben Willis
daily Marches On City Hall for an entire
summer and in 1963 in October you see
250 000 students stay out of school in a
single day for Freedom Day those
students some of them just stayed home
some of them went to Freedom schools
sort of touting back to Mississippi and
the freedom schools there during the
Civil Rights Movement and so that's sort
of the big peak of my own research is
this Freedom Day movement so I look at
what came before and what sort of came
after basically we see this big mass
movement coming into this Freedom Day
time and after that in 1966 so a few
years later Ben Willis superintendent
steps down Martin Luther King enters the
scene in Chicago starts fighting for
fair housing and that's sort of how the
story goes from there we see obviously
schools are not equal in Chicago still
so the fight is still going but that's
sort of the Civil Rights era in a box as
far as Chicago schools go
thank you
thanks for this presentation in studying
the history of like these sort of
movements
sort of shared or different positions
that student organizers or parental
organizers played with each other
each other organizing
along yeah so there's like a lot of
different groups that play in Chicago
for sure and across the board but
certainly in Chicago there's different
neighborhoods there's different groups
of people you see teachers organizing
you see students organizing you see
parents organizing you see and then you
sort of see these like civil rights
people who they're like professional
organized or some of them right and so
with students I think you see them
fighting really particularly in the
later period for the most part so in the
sort of 65-66 era but you start to see
high schoolers starting to fight really
hard in those issues of like curriculum
or they want better lunch rooms so
really
um distinct things I guess as opposed to
these civil rights organizations are a
little more Broad in what they want
right they want to change the policies
in the city and these other like the
high schoolers for example really want
to fix the one thing that's happening in
their high school so that's I guess the
biggest difference I would say
so hi everyone amanshi I'm a second year
Master's student in the Council of East
Asian studies pursuing anthropology
today I want to quickly walk through my
ethnographic field work exploring
African migrants experiences in Iwo
China
so first where and what is you you is
one of the satellite cities of the
Metropolis Shanghai it is not a big city
but it has the largest wholesale Market
in the world with over 75 000 stores now
surprisingly it is a Gathering Place for
Traders especially those from African
countries seeking cheap mating China
Goods
in 2018 there were over 3 000 African
permanent residents living there
but a pandemic has changed many things
many African Traders were either
deported or voluntarily left because of
China's covered containment policies my
own research was forced to end early due
to a sudden lockdown in the city
still for one and a half months I worked
with a African Traders
from Nigeria Ghana Ben and Uganda Somali
and Senegal and used participant
observation and semi-structured
interviews to understand their migratory
experiences
first one having four men and I
discussed most were the insecurities
anxiety over Mobility China's travel ban
has prevented known citizens from
entering the countries while these
Traders work hinges on Mobility
running Logistics businesses they used
to receive African buyers flying to
China frequently however as normal
buyers are traveling to China and online
wholesale entities such as Alibaba have
expanded into African countries many of
these Traders expressed a sense of
precarity
seeing their position as middlemen
destabilized but I found that by
maintaining good reputation and
capitalizing on the mutual suspicion
between African clients and Chinese
business owners this middleman were
still able to navigate the pandemic
because of their social capital
race and racism also emerged as Central
topics in my work rather than treating
race as a static notion I study it as an
interactive process in which different
groups of people interact in a highly
contingent manner that shapes the idea
of race and racial experiences in EU I
found that racism especially against
African males has been linked to
mythologies about black males
hypersexuality at the same time even
though many Chinese business owners see
the presence of African Traders as a
Hallmark of China's globalization
they also treat the presence of
Blackness
as a sign of China's temporary
entanglements with the third world and
even barbarianism that needs to be
eradicated in order to fulfill their
fantasy of China becoming a first world
country despite my short time you knew
the topics I explore there are ones that
I will continue to explore in my own
mathesis thank you so much
foreign
[Applause]
quarantine and hotel and then go to the
City and then also facing the um sudden
lockdown in the city yeah so it was
pretty hectic but at the same also I
have to negotiate my positionality as a
female young scholars because I
constantly
um receive like warnings from Chinese
people regarding
um the the the thing I talk about which
is like African males hypersexuality so
actually so that's why I think that
rather than studying on Race as a really
static notion I want to see like how
people
interact together and constructs the
idea of race and racism together yeah so
I think that's two of my main challenges
yeah thank you
thank you
hi everyone my name is Babette I'm a
second year in the department of
African-American American studies so my
work this summer actually changed course
quite a bit from what I originally
mapped out I was supposed to do some
research at this archival collection at
Fisk University and had confirmed my
appointment at the beginning of the
summer but they had a change in
management and we're no longer accepting
appointments until late fall
so I'm left with this flight from JFK to
Nashville and this reservation at a
three-star motel that I'm not really
completely sure what to do with
I'm happy to say that what I was able to
come up with is something that I've been
wanting to do for years and that I think
ultimately really help Advance some of
my research on my analysis of Southern
black radio programs in the mid to late
20th century
but before I get into that I think it's
important to back up and give a little
background on my research
one of the main radio stations that I
look at my research is wdia which is the
first all black programmed radio station
to go on the air in the U.S in 1948 in
Memphis Tennessee
so in my research I analyzed recordings
of wdia and draw out the intimate
relationships between black hosts and
black Memphis listeners I analyze these
recordings through the lens of affect
and haptic Theory and think about what
it means that wdia provided material
Comfort to those living amidst the
state-sanctioned violence of a
segregationist regime
for example when recording in particular
in this collection of recordings that I
listen to is in oral history with a
woman named Joe Evelyn Grayson
Joe Evelyn Grayson has now passed on but
I believe she was 40 at the time of this
recording and she talks about how as a
kid growing up in Memphis wdia is what
she heard in the morning as well as in
the evening when she went back to sleep
it completely framed her day
jovelyn Grayson was born in 1948 in
Memphis living in one of the five or so
black neighborhoods in Memphis at the
time this is also the same year that
someone very special was born black
feminist scholar and literary and
cultural theorist Hortense Spillers who
was also born in a black neighborhood in
Memphis
during Professor spiller's time in
college while she was protesting for the
integration of diners through sit-ins
Hortense Spillers or Tennessee as her
family calls her also found the time to
be a radio DJ at wdia
she's one of the few women to work at
the station at the time in the 60s and
she had a music segment every weekend
where she played songs and talked on the
air going by the name of Honey girl
sitting in her Nashville home Professor
Spillers has me buckling over in
laughter at her impersonation of a white
manager at the station with a big
overbite who she wasn't particularly
fond of
she provides me insight into how she
navigated the station as a dark-skinned
black woman and how in some ways she
felt the men at the station actually
protected her
but she also confirmed some of my
suspicions that the station was not as
outwardly political as I had hoped that
nobody other than her really made
statements about segregation on the air
I'm so deeply grateful to have spent
this time conducting this oral history
with Professor spellers a fellow radio
producer and DJ
I don't believe there's any other
published or written work about her time
at wdia so I'm excited to not only
include this in my research but also to
continue working with the archivists at
Brown University to have this oral
history included with her collection of
papers
I was so happy to learn also that Joel
and Grayson the woman whose recordings I
have not listened to for hours and hours
and Professor Spiller has actually known
each other and gone to school together
at Burger T Washington High and Memphis
University she leaned back and said yes
of course I knew her when I brought up
her name thank you so much
[Applause]
like
archives
yeah so most of the collections from
wdia are held at Indiana University and
a lot of them are digitized which is
really nice so the stuff of joemly
Grayson is like online
um
I don't think the radio station itself
has very well organized archives but
Indiana University has some of them
awesome thank you so much
[Applause]
hi everybody so before how did this work
okay before I start I wanted to quickly
just give a brief background to uh
essentially my project and
um
uh yeah just kind of and also my um what
I do here so I am a second year PhD
student in anthropology I also will be
um taking the wgss certificate
um so
um
yeah my larger project as you can see
um so hopefully oh you're actually
starting oh okay I didn't realize okay
so um my project is about black British
game um and queer CIS men and how they
negotiate space and place in the gay
community so I'm interested in their
experiences within um certain gay and
queer spaces but also what it means to
be black British and gain the 21st
century so their experiences more
broadly
um so I'm going to be talking
particularly about uh this day
um and this particular so this is just a
picture I got from Google so but um I
was yeah so this is an old picture but
anyway
um so this particular thing I want to
talk about is just research and fun and
a fun Saturday night out in unexpected
places so
um I didn't expect this particular
research that took place to happen and
then
um for the people that I spoke to my
interlocutors this was a Saturday night
in what I call an unexpected place so
basically it was a Saturday uh evening I
uh it was it August I was about to come
back to the US and I needed suitcase so
I went to Central London
um and a particular place called Oxford
Street went to a particular stores it
was closing I wanted to see if I get big
suitcase there was no luck so I thought
let me go down to Soho which is a
particular area in London and this is
called
um
Old Compton Street so there's a lot of
gay it's a gay area along here also like
just lots of gay spaces and clubs and
bars anyway so I
um
uh was walking down the street I I went
to this bar and I just stood outside and
was watching and um wanted to see
um if you know I could interact with
people but it was very very busy it was
late at night like 10 o'clock in the
evening anyway I decided to walk down
this street and just here in the corner
here I saw three black people standing
there so two black guys and a girl and
so I walked past and I was like I need
to talk to them but I was a bit you know
scared so I walked past and then I came
back and I spoke to them anyway we
started speaking and um I you know tell
them about my research one of them was a
bit you know
um kind of like not sure was looking at
me like what's this guy talking about
and then another one was you know a bit
more um enthusiastic and the other one
was just a bit more quiet anyway I asked
them what they were doing
um I told them about my project and they
um told me that they were just standing
there like talking having drinks blah
blah um there was an intention to go out
somewhere anyway in the end I found out
that they didn't go anywhere
um and they stood there for the whole
night just having a come station talking
having fun and drinking so basically the
point of this presentation today was to
essentially highlight the fact that
actually you can find uh you can find
research happen sorry activity happening
in spaces that you don't expect so I
didn't expect to go and find that people
will be here having fun and they were
that was their night out they were in
the corner
um just kind of having fun amongst a
busy busy night where so much was going
on they were just there talking to each
other having fun so essentially I didn't
expect to find that and I think that's
also something that I've realized in
terms of like thinking about space and
place and thinking about where you're
going to find research and where people
enjoy themselves
um it's made me think Anew about those
kind of Concepts and where you can find
research and where people might enjoy
themselves because of the time I can't
go into too much detail but yeah thank
you that's essentially what happened
[Applause]
you're thinking about your project
um
yes
it did
um because I as I as I said I didn't
expect you right oh sorry
um yes it did because I didn't expect as
I was saying to find
I I didn't think about the street as a
site of research basically
um I
you know I went initially to
um on the street there's a like a bar
club called Gay which is uh quite famous
actually and I um
I I stood out I was gonna go inside but
I stood outside just kind of like
watching
and um yeah just seeing if I'll be able
to speak to people coming out or going
in even
um so anyway there was no luck there and
I decided to just walk around the street
just to kind of observe what was going
on
um and then I just saw those three
individuals there and
that particular corner it was quite
significant because it was just in the
midst of so much going on they were just
standing there you probably wouldn't
maybe even notice
um had if I wasn't paying attention I
probably wouldn't have even noticed so
it has changed my mind in a sense of
maybe going around when I walk on these
streets so maybe I actually just speak
to people on the street instead and I
never thought about that and so it's got
me thinking about maybe observing more
Street action
um because a lot of things actually do
happen on the street so um yeah there
was more to the story as well but
obviously I didn't have as much time but
it definitely has made me thinking new
about different spaces in which you can
yeah um research and maybe even find
interlocutors so thank you
hi everyone my name is Thomas and I'm a
second year in a PhD in history of
science and medicine and early modern
studies
so what if I told you that poisonous
snakes infectious diseases like rabies
and transatlantic chattel slavery all
converge in the development and
collection of some of the world's first
standardized sets of biomarkers
these seemingly disparate forces came
into contact with each other in the
colonial Atlantic and my project seeks
to investigate and understand the
Fallout of those encounters
for the purposes of today's talk I ask
us to specifically consider 16th to 19th
century European colonizing Enterprises
in the Caribbean
these historical events brought many
different people from far from places
together and one of the key
ramifications of these meetings from an
epidemiological perspective was the
increasingly frequent outbreak of
seemingly novel diseases from a European
perspective
in this light the Caribbean a site of
varied and intertwined histories of
domination and subjugation of enslaved
peoples was often described as an
inhospitable Place filled with disease
and suffering
but it was also a location of great
opportunity from a European colonizing
perspective and outside the familiar
histories of the search for gold and
silver or the establishment of a brutal
Plantation complex the Caribbean also
served as an excellent testing ground
for new medical theories and treatments
the reasons for this for manifold there
were a greater number of diseases to
examine than there were in Europe the
enslaved African population provided a
ready-made class of unconsenting test
subjects and the Lush Island topography
presented plentiful new plants and
animals with which medical professionals
could fashion new drugs
therefore Caribbean colonialism fostered
and encouraged medical Innovation on a
large scale I argue
the findings from my recent archival
research one page of which you will see
on the top right of the screen here
demonstrate a concerted effort to
collect enormous sets of medical data
that linked patients bio biographical
information alongside their maladies as
well as data about the time of year and
environmental conditions such as
temperature and barometric pressure
these sources indicate a sophisticated
level of thinking about the social and
environmental determinants of Health in
the colonial Caribbean something that
biomedicine today still struggles to get
its head wrapped around
I also found more fraud evidence of
human experimentation with poisons on
terminally ill patients
specifically French Physicians conducted
a series of experiments with Viper's
Venom on rabies patients in the 1760s
the findings of which eventually helped
Louis Pasteur develop the first rabies
vaccine
the Venom was derived from the landsat
Viper from Martinique where it was used
in exploitative experiments and to
torture enslaved Africans
here we see how poison was
simultaneously a tool of subjugation in
the Caribbean and a miraculous
medicament in Europe
from this brief overview I'll leave you
with one simple question
how might these entangled histories of
slavery experimentation and medical
Innovation give us pause in believing in
the invaluability of the modern medicine
that they helped create
[Applause]
so I see a picture there in the corner
like what are some of the kind of like
archival like sources and documents that
you use to like think about like this
yeah so it's a it's a variety of things
from treatises on like what a disease
actually is and how you might get
infected because that was up for debate
but also these statistical tables based
on trying to like determine whether
climate actually does impact somebody's
susceptibility to disease and then also
transcripts from medical
experimentations themselves yeah
thanks
good afternoon everyone my name is
Abigail Calderon I am a second year
history student in the PHD I focus on
latinx businesses in 20th century as
social cultural and political anchors
this summer with the help of ritm I
exploited the I explored the Roybal
Edward papers and the bra and the
Bradley mayor Tom Administration papers
at the University of California Los
Angeles
I wanted to take the opportunity to
examine these collections in conjunction
to research the period between the
Federal Highway Act of 1956 and the
rebuild LA and the rebuild La program
created by then then mayor Tom Bradley
to rebuild Los Angeles after the Los
Angeles uprisings
in order to study Urban disinvestment
and reinvestment specifically how latinx
and small businesses reacted to changes
in government spending
although I had intended to spend equal
amounts of time on both collections I
ended up focusing a majority of my time
on the Bradley collection because it's
centered businesses as the backbone of
Los Angeles
uh with this three different themes
emerged one was the language that the
city of Los Angeles employed after the
Los Angeles uprisings in order to
establish diversity as a positive
strength and itself is a microcosm of
the nation in order to continue to
attract business
two was how they treated the homeless
population during their efforts to
re-centralize uh LA's downtown business
district
and finally how latinx businesses were
writing to express different social and
political concerns during this time
for instance I included a letter from
the
um from the Mexican Grocers Association
that wrote to express discontent after a
government agent from the ins came to
give a talk and implied that immigrants
were drug dealers this is exemplary of
different of how different businesses
were not only writing about fiscal
concerns but also about social and
political concerns
um overall My Summer research
specifically on the Bradley collection
helped me identify different
stakeholders amongst latinx businesses
and how the city was attempting to
Rebrand itself to continue attracting
business and finally how is prioritizing
different businesses and different
people in order to attempt to
recentralize and the Roybal collection
allowed me to get some context on the
Federal Highway Act
thank you very much
[Applause]
all right there was there any particular
thread that you like men I have been
looking for when you were kind of coming
into the archive but this year you're
hoping to kind of further explore not as
you come across these sources yourself
uh yeah so one thing that I was not at
all expecting to find was conversations
on skid row and the homeless population
in Los Angeles I I was originally
intending to look at the
recentralization of the of the business
district and how it affected uh
businesses and the communities they
served but what I ended up finding was a
lot on sort of the homeless population
and how the city was sort of talking
about them and it was uh
a really interesting language around
like a quote-unquote like a skid row
mentality and so I think that even
though it's not directly related to my
research I'm I want to explore that
because I think it really sort of lays
out the city's priorities
foreign
hi everyone thank you for being here my
name is Jess and I'm a second year in
the history Department
um and I'm going to be presenting on
some of the archival material that I saw
this summer while I was back home at the
University of Miami at the Cuban
Heritage collection specifically
so pictured here are some donation cards
that were mainly in circulation spanning
through the 1960s up until the 1980s
which were considered the peak years of
La Guerra Polo Camino De Mundo or the
war across the paths of the world or
kind of like the war against communism
across Latin America and the Caribbean
as it was deployed by anti-castro Cuban
Exile terrorist organizations
so I'm going to be focusing on alphasis
today which is all of the donation bonds
kind of they're all sponsored by that
organization specifically which was
founded in 1961 and the organization
whose collection had like the most
amount of boxes and I was able to focus
on the most this summer so with chapters
across the United States Venezuela
Puerto
Rico's membership was made up of Cuban
Exiles that were Central to the war to
the US's war against the island
throughout the night the late 1950s and
1960s and up until today and many of
them directly trained by the CIA were
directly trained by the CIA with
involvement
um and we're involved in the
orchestrating of the Bay of Pigs
invasion in 1961. and also a lot of the
men that these funds are kind of being
donated for were men that were also
involved in like the first couple of
years of the July 26 movement leading up
to the Triumph of the Cuban Revolution
and abandoned soon afterwards and what
I'm attempting to begin arguing through
the analysis of these donation cards and
also kind of a lot of the other things
that I saw which were kind of like these
letters to presidents ambassadors and
other politicians across Latin America
and the Caribbean is how rather than
weekend after the CIA ceased to fund
Alpha santises publicly these
organizations became more transnational
so in the sense that they began to see
their Perpetual war against the Cuban
Revolution as one that began to
Encompass the urgency to contain
Communism across the hemisphere
so the funds collected through these
donation cards either directly or
indirectly helped facilitate the
exportation of these tactics of Terrors
these skill these skills that they were
trained through the CIA with and some of
these examples that I saw were kind of
like bomb construction kidnappings
assassinations boat attacks and also the
legal defense of Cuban Exiles that were
detained after these acts
um by the government's where most of
these acts of terrorism were carried out
or kind of organized
um and some examples being Venezuela
Puerto Rico Chile and Mexico and one of
the examples is kind of like the
donation Bond that's all the way to the
right uh wait you're left and kind of
the way that um a lot of Cuban Exiles
were advocating for the extradition of
Orlando Walsh who was one of um at the
time where respond was responsible for
the bombing of the Kawana flight 455 in
1976 and the Venezuela the Venezuelan
government had detained in Bosch for 11
years so some of the questions that I'm
thinking about is the language that is
used in these donation cards and how
Cuban Exiles were reacting to these acts
of terrorism both Cuban migrants that
were living across Latin America and the
Caribbean specifically
Venezuela during the 1970s and the 1980s
and how Exiles in the US were also
reacting to those trials
um and the questions that I'm kind of
left with is how do these bonds show
what executive members of alpha Senti
saw this recovery to entail this
recovery of Cuba
um and yeah kind of tracing what
Invasion meant what invading Cuba meant
throughout the 1970s and the 1980s and
how it involved right-wing movements in
countries like Venezuela
sorry that was really good
this is simple I love the um like your
archive to study here I was wondering if
you could just you know share more about
some of your initial observations about
the differences or similarities in
language across all of these various
archives and maybe if you felt like a
different typography
yeah
oh I'm sorry so one of the things that I
see a lot a lot of and like it's
something that I would want to I would
want to flesh out is the way that they
use like Jose Maddie quotes and the way
that they use images of like the war of
like the independence Wars in Cuba and
kind of how they appropriate
um how they appropriate them so kind of
like
independencia kind of using a fusilla
kind of the
um kind of the gun also using just even
kind of like like just using kind of
like
the idea of like a
like and kind of
um how they're thinking about Cuban
Exile nationalism or whatever that means
in connection with
um these Independence Wars and how it's
like this Perpetual war that they are
continuing from
um Cuban Independence uh so I think
that's kind of something that I saw that
really connected
um
yeah I'm trying I'm trying to think of
other things but I think that's kind of
one thread that I'm thinking a lot about
right now
thank you for asking
[Applause]
Sylvia Ryerson I'm a fifth year uh PhD
in American studies and um the ritm
summer research Fellowship supported
three months of ethnographic and
archival research in Southwest Virginia
and Eastern Kentucky for my dissertation
project calls from home listening past
cultural power in central Appalachia and
so from the end of May until August
through August I was based in Harlan
County Kentucky pursuing multiple
threads of my dissertation project and
so I wanted to share this image for my
presentation because one of the
highlights of my summer was getting to
work with and learn from The Higher
Ground theater company which is based
out of the local community college in
Harlan and this is this is an image from
their work which I really think captures
their community-based methodologies and
practice and so the man in the black
shirt is Benny Massey who is a former
underground coal miner and a Beloved
Community activist who lives in the
small town of Lynch Kentucky and who I
was able to interview and learn from
this summer
and so Lynch was built by the U.S colon
cope company which was a subsidiary of
U.S steel which was built as a
company-owned town to house coal miners
and their families in 1917. it was a
segregated coal camp that became the
destination for thousands of black
families during the first wave of the
Great Migration from the Deep South as
Coal Company recruiters went to Alabama
and neighboring states to entice or
coerce former sharecroppers and combat
lease miners to come work as waged
laborers in the Kentucky coal fields
and despite unsafe exploitative and
racist living and working conditions
black Miners and their families turned
this corner of Southeast Kentucky into a
powerful cultural center with deep roots
in the region
and alongside my research in Lynch I
actually was able to serve as a teaching
assistant for a 12-week summer course at
the higher ground theater company was
teaching in the Harlan County Jail
serving as an assistant for their
Appalachian studies class and learning
from and with the people with the people
in the Harlan County Jail about the
conditions of their life and
incarceration in Harlan County
and so the support from RIT I'm really
made it possible for me to be in the
community for such an extended amount of
time and really able to work closely and
collaboratively with the scholars and
artists in the region who are doing such
important work and who made so many of
my own connections possible and
additionally I was very fortunate to
receive an ritm Conference travel award
which supported my travel to Indiana to
give a paper presentation at the
American political histories conference
titled the past present and future of
American democracy at Purdue University
where I presented uh as a part of a
paper panel session on Appalachia and
energy politics with other Appalachian
Scholars thanks
so could you say a little bit more about
the yeah yeah yeah and so I sort of had
to jump between two really I was sort of
the research I was doing in Lynch is
sort of part of chapter two of the
dissertation and the teaching in the
harling county jail is part of chapter
five and it's looking at these different
nodes of the cultural state in central
Appalachia including state prisons
federal prisons the county jail
um and tracing that back to the roots of
um convict lease labor in Alabama and so
and um obviously the afterlives of
slavery and many other systems of
extraction in the region and um and so I
think in a way what I was trying to
balance and what sort of both histories
are present in Harlan County is both um
these deep roots of um
of
um black migration into Appalachia
um and sort of how race relations in the
at the turn of the century
um structured labor relations in
Appalachia throughout the century and
then also how how you know those those
foundations have also
um created the conditions of possibility
for the kind of jail expansion that's
happening there today
hello
my name is Josh I'm a second year
history PhD my research focuses on
Modern intellectual history and
specifically the changing debate about
race and the place of Jews in post-war
Europe among largely francophone
intellectuals roughly in the time frame
between the Algerian war of independence
and the 1967 war in israel-palestine I
used my RTM summer travel Grant to go to
a conference that was called hijacking
memory in Berlin it was according to the
organizers probably one of the first
conferences it held in post-war Germany
that directly discussed
um the Holocaust and Colonial violence
together on the same stage this is a
major Taboo in German culture it's
because there is a complicated political
Legacy about relativizing the Holocaust
in German culture the Holocaust is the
greatest evil that Humanity ever carried
out and nothing can ever be compared to
it and in some places intellectuals who
compare say the ethnic cleansing of
Palestine during the nakba or
um
German uh violence in its African
colonies to the Holocaust actually can
face
um really serious uh academic and
professional consequences so there was a
little bit of an ongoje uh element to
the conference
um but the there was also
um like proximate political
um reasons for it being held there as
well which is that in Europe the new
right has sort of flipped the valence of
anti-Semitism so whereas say before 1980
what it meant to be on the far right in
Europe was to be bluntly anti-semitic
now the xenophobic far-right in Germany
and in France and elsewhere Poland
Hungary has used a kind of phylosematic
argument to block the flow of immigrants
from largely from the Middle East so for
instance in Germany the if day which is
in some sense uh the sort of successor
of Neo-Nazi parties has opposed the uh
the German government's immigration
plans to have Syrian refugees come on
the grounds that the Syrian refugees are
going to bring in anti-Semitism into
Germany
um and so all of this is being discussed
at the conference
um and uh what ended up happening was
that the controversy that the conference
was meant to address actually blew up
during the conference and two polish
academics criticized uh publicly and
went to the German press over uh the
remarks of a Palestinian scholar named
bocconi who explicitly compared the
nakba to the Holocaust and um
this kind of there was a media Firestone
storm in Germany over this right-wing
German politicians called for the
defunding of the venue or the Conference
was held which is called the house of
world cultures
and I ended up covering this for a
magazine that I work for called Jewish
currents which the article was called
The Challenge of Defending memory in
Germany which was about the sort of New
Politics of anti-Semitism or
anti-anti-semitism and how they're
connected to uh xenophobia in Europe
immigration and the legacies of
colonialism
[Applause]
go ahead
[Music]
and um
why that
that order
why that might
how they navigate
yeah so uh Tariq was ended up being fine
and and a lot of the conference
participants who were there signed a
petition kind of in support of him and
there ended up it turned out that he had
a lot of support there and it did I
don't think it had
um severe consequences on his life he
runs a Palestinian Think Tank called
al-shabika which you should all check
out if you're interested in that sort of
thing where they are probably at The
Cutting Edge of Palestinian Politics As
for like the German sort of relative
relativization debate that sort of it
blew up in the in the 80s at first
because initially the comparisons were
between was it possible to compare
um the Soviet Gulag system to the Nazi
camp system that was what was sort of
the first historians debate in Germany
and that's kind of where things were
um and you know generally was a far
right talking point
um to compare uh because right-wingers
who maybe or maybe not had some kind of
Nazi affiliation were saying look the
Communists also had camps so it's not
just the not it's not just the Nazi
thing it was also it's like there were
bad guys on both sides that's the
background for why the politics of
comparison is is very hard but also
um the
part of Germany's Rehabilitation into
the family of Nations after its
unification has entailed German the
German State being explicitly Zionist
so part of the Germans what Germany
conceives of as its national interests
is the protection of the sovereign state
of of Israel and so that makes
um say discourse about the Palestinians
or really any kind of anti-colonial
politics not just kind of uh
it makes it a threat to what the state
has conceived of as its um basically
[Applause]
all right thank you Josh thank you
everybody
um really appreciate all the presenters
sharing their work you know this is the
kind of work that we want to continue to
support so we hope you will come back
and continue to seek support here in
ritm and that Spirit I'll also invite
you to come on Wednesdays we have
writing Wednesdays from 9 30 to 11 30
and and 10 in the weeks to come to have
coffee and breakfast food and hope that
you and others will gather here and do
some of your own writing
um uh and that you'll continue to see
one another because I think one of the
things that I so appreciate in listening
to you is uh the reminder of how much we
all have to learn from one another that
after all much of our education really
does come from come horizontally if you
want to think about it that way from
one's peers and the people who are doing
some of the most important research on
campus so with that thank you so much we
invite you out we actually have some
food for you and we hope that you
continue the conversation there thanks
again
thank you
[Music]
foreign